اتواجد الان في احد المناطق السكنيه في
مدينه اومان وسط اوكرانيا هذه المدينه
التي تعرضت لقصف صاروخي الروسي فجر هذا
اليوم وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه هذا البناء
كما تشاهدون تعرض لاضرار بالغه نتيجه
القصف هنالك قتلى وجرحى في صفوف المدنيين
وفقا للسلطات المحليه هنا مرت ساعات طويله
السلطات وفرق الدفاع المدني كما علمنا ما
زالت داخل البناء تعمل على انتشال مزيد من
الجثه وتبحث بين الانقاض عن ناجين في صفوف
المدنيين وهذا القصف في الحقيقه هو جزء من
قصف واسع كبير تعرضت له عمان الحديث عن
عشرات المباني ايضا تعرضت للقصف والحديث
ايضا عن احراق العديد من او احتراق العديد
من المركبات الخاصه بالسكان المحليين في
هذا المكان وفي الح هذا القصف تزامنا
وترافق مع قصف اخر تعرضت له العاصمه
استهدفت هناك البنيه التحتيه لا سيما قطاع
الكهرباء والماء في عدد من المناطق
والحديث عن قتلى وجرحى في مقاطعات جنوبيه
لا سيما في
الشرق ايضا كل ذلك دفع الرئيس الاوكراني
الى القول بان من يتورط في قتل الشعب
الاوكراني لن يفلت من العقاب وان القوات
الاوكرانيه ستواصل القتال حتى اخراج كامل
القوات الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تامر صمادي الجزيره اومان وسط اوكرانيا